i feel like girls don't even know what
like they want because they'll say they
want one thing and then they'll date a
completely different like they'll say
they want the nice guy but like they'll
stay with the guy that's cheated them on
them like three times so it's like okay
so what are you sorry for me what is
that because i need to know what that as
a woman what do you think that is
if a woman does that
um
i mean i think there's like
like staying with a guy that cheated on
you or like not going or saying you want
something and like
both
okay um
this is kind of how i see it like i
think a lot of girls like see like red
flags early and you kind of see like how
this guy is but you're like attracted to
something about him maybe
um right and you're kind of just hoping
like you'll be the girl that changes him
all right so
this is the thing like i think that's
a woman tried to do the same thing to me
once which is why it it's why i asked
you just to see if it was the the the
correct answer
so
your you get attracted to somebody with
an edge
because that's what attracted you to
yeah okay
and then all of a sudden
as you get more comfortable
the edge starts to
you start to wanna i guess sand down the
edge you know you want to make the edge
a little bit smoother
but then what you do is that you um
you take away from what you're attracted
to in the first place
yeah well i think sometimes like
that edge isn't good for like long-term
relationships you know
like sometimes like the thing that
attracted girls to them isn't
like
it kind of gets old after a while
right so like in a long-term
relationship it's not overly like
sustainable i guess
okay so when you were saying also that
you know women say they want a certain
type of guy and then they go for another
guy
um
you know
there's a saying nice guys finish lost
you know that's saying's been around for
a very very long time yeah
and um
i guess the older i've got the kind of
i've been like
you know what sometimes sometimes they
do a lot like they do nice guys do
finish last a lot
and um
but the type of woman who stays with a
guy who treats her like
absolute [ __ ] like i don't like what is
that
um
what is that
that's hard um
because we're trying to understand out
here
um
what is that i mean i don't
um
sorry i'm like trying to give a good
well thought out answer i would say
girls
like
start to become more like
at least my friends but i i have to say
like i grew up in a very like privileged
upbringing like all my friends parents
were married
um my parents were like i i grew up in a
very different environment than some
people but for me like
it only lasts for so long like after a
while like they end the girls end up
either dumping them or the guy ends up
like cheating and then they end up
leaving and like marrying a guy they can
more see a future with
but i know there's some girls that like
do that into their 30s and 40s i just
like don't know them
so
so a woman who stays with a guy who's
constantly cheating yeah
and treats her like crap yeah
she's constantly crying to her friends
yeah but then she's constantly going
back to them
because as men
our threshold is different if a woman's
constantly treating us a certain way or
whatever
at some point in time we're going to be
like all right see you later yeah
whereas women will stay around for
longer
yeah i just don't know any girls that
didn't leave eventually
right okay like that's what i'm saying
like they do it for so like my sister is
one i can think of my oldest sister um
she was married to a guy for like 10
years and i don't want to like put her
business out there but he like
he was not good
um but then like after 10 years she just
got tired of it and left him and like
married a different guy and had like
more kids with him and like now her new
husband's great
um so
i think because there was a there was a
tv show on netflix there was a show on
netflix called um sex life did you see
that
right and it was basically about this
married woman had the perfect life
perfect like
however she kept wondering about this
bad guy that she'd been with in the past
and she kept on pining for him and all
this kind of stuff whereas on the
surface
her life was perfect
um
but i feel like i don't know maybe
i don't know what that is in the in in
the psyche of females that does that
well i think they talk about it like in
the manosphere they call it like the
alpha guy and the beta guy like they
want the alpha guy like to hook up with
but they want to have like and even have
their kids but they want the beta guy to
like raise them
i don't know how like
because it's hard because i can't you
can't really define alpha and beta
so that's where i get kind of like
tricky with the manosphere but right
what makes you want to
learn about the mana sphere though as a
woman
um
i really like psychology
so i think the psychology of dating is
really interesting
um
yeah i would say like that's the main
reason i learned and it's like
interesting to hear like
the what guys try to do to like get
girls like i don't know like it's like
oh i i know that game i don't know like
right um because some of it like i i've
learned like some stuff from like pickup
and like building girls like investment
and like attachment and i thought that
stuff was really interesting too
hmm